You're not just anyone
you're here for a reason and even if it takes
you the rest of your life you owe it to yourself
to find out what that reason is goodbye my
son our hopes and dreams travel with you
he always believed you were meant for greater
things that when the day came your shoulders would
be able to bear the weight what if a child dreamed
of becoming something other than what society had
intended for him or her what if a child aspired
to something greater my son was in the bus
he saw what clark did what was i supposed to do
just let him die there's more at stake here than
just our lives clark you have to keep this side of
yourself a secret how do you find someone who has
spent a lifetime covering his tracks you've grown
stronger than i ever could have imagined keep
testing your limits 20 years in gotham how many
good guys are left how many stayed that way
i have so many questions where do i come from
why did you send me here you're as much a
child of earth now as you are of krypton
you can save them you can save all of them
your world has sheltered one of my citizens
surrender within 24 hours or watch this
world suffer one day you're gonna have to
make a choice a choice of whether to stand
proud in front of the human race or not
can you imagine how people
on this planet would react
if they knew there was someone like this out there
men fall from the sky the gods hurl thunderbolts
count the dead thousands of people he has
the power to wipe out the entire human race
you're gonna go to war he is not
our enemy bruce please tell me
you will
a hundred years ago i walked away from mankind
from the century of horus men made a world
where standing together is impossible
superman was never real just the dream of a
farmer from kansas men are still good we fight
we kill we betray one another but we can
do better we have to go i love you no god
we'll give the people of earth
an ideal to strive towards
the bell's been wrung
the god is dead and they've heard it
i failed him in life
a whole failing death you have to stand
together help me find the others like you
find this frozen you have to find that
in time they will join you in the sun
in time you will help them accomplish wonders
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new justice league snyder cut trilogy trailer
bet you didn't see that coming warner brothers
just dropped this so i'll explain what's going
on and what the state of things are because zack
snyder did have a trilogy of movies planned as
part of his five movie arc starting with man
of steel and ending with justice league three
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there'll be a lot
more dc movie stuff happening in the next couple
of months there was also a recent interview with
the writer of the movie chris terrio who also
wrote batman v superman so i'll explain what he
said he provided a better look at what's going on
behind the scenes at the studio and zack snyder
has also done a lot of interviews talking about
what he thinks is going to be going on with the
future of his movies the funny thing too is
that if you look at chris terrio's imdb page
it looks like somebody added justice league 2 in
development like there's an actual justice league
snyder cut sequel that's happening but i believe
that's not true imdb is like a wikipedia style
page where anybody can add anything to those pages
so just because you're seeing justice league 2
on his page doesn't mean that that's actually
happening but just talking about this trilogy
trailer first the way that warner brothers
cut this they're basically calling the three
dc movies that zack snyder directed the
justice league snyder cut trilogy now he is
credited as a producer on all the dc movies
that feature characters that he originated
like he was a producer on the wonder woman movie
he did help patty jenkins with that a little he
even had a cameo scene during the movie that you
all spotted but by the time they got into like
wonder woman 1984 a couple years down the road i
think his producer credits started to be more of
vanity credits and he didn't do as much work as he
did on the first movie like he probably just gave
patty jenkins creative feedback on the film and
offered support behind the scenes but he wasn't
running around on the set of the movie the way
he was during the first wonder woman movie and
i think it's the same thing for the aquaman movie
that james wan did like zack snyder mostly just
offers some creative input behind the scenes
he wasn't running around the set with james wan
the five movie arc that zack snyder spoke about
during interviews recently that he had planned
was man of steel batman v superman than the
three justice league movies but before he started
talking about his arc of dc movies originally i'd
also assume that he would do a direct man of steel
2 sequel to the first henry cavill film but the
funny thing is the way zack snyder explained it
he actually designed justice league 3 the
last movie in the trilogy to be a direct
man of steel sequel because it would have been
mostly centered on superman's character he would
have been featured way more prominently than
most of the other justice league characters
a lot of the justice league snyder cud movie that
we all just got done watching the four hour cut
does revolve around superman but in that movie
he's really only featured on screen for a small
portion of that four hour run time so presumably
justice league three would have been the last dc
movie zack snyder had planned on directing i mean
you never say never but then i think his idea was
that he would transition to more of a behind the
scenes producer role and just pass the torch to
someone else the same way that christopher nolan
passed the torch onto other people and said that
he wasn't going to do more dc movies like if you
don't remember christopher nolan actually was a
producer and did help zack snyder make the man
of steel movie mostly offering creative input
during the film making process that's why you see
him at all the behind the scenes walking around
the set with zack snyder he was also one of the
people who told zack snyder to never ever watch
the theatrical cut of justice league after he left
the project which i think was solid advice for him
zack snyder did already release his original story
treatment for both the justice league sequels
2 and 3. now he referred to them as justice league
2a and 2b during his original pitch to the studio
because i think they'd originally pitched them
structurally the same way like marvel had pitched
avengers infinity war remember the original
avengers infinity war teaser from comic-con
way back in 2015 i think it was it was just thanos
in the infinity gauntlet spinning around and then
the title reveal but at the time the title was
avengers infinity war part 1 in part 2. they said
that they changed the title of part 2 to avengers
end game because by the time they had finished
writing the script it no longer felt like a part
2 and i think they're correct avengers infinity
war is a completely different movie tonally than
avengers end game so i think it was kind of the
same idea with zack snyder in the justice league
sequels and he did say that he had already come up
with the titles for all the justice league sequels
like he wasn't going to call it justice league
2 in justice league 3. i believe based on the
story treatment justice league 2 was going to
be called justice league united and you can just
leave all your guesses and your predictions for
what justice league three's title would have been
i've already done a full breakdown video of what
that story outline was and what happens to the
characters and where the story goes and how they
end justice league 3 so i'll post a link for that
video in the description the story was pretty epic
there are a couple controversial twists with what
they do with this crazy love triangle with batman
lois lane and superman and batman's supposed
secret love child with lois lane in the future
but overall it would have been a pretty epic
story but just to explain what's happening
now in terms of zack snyder in the future of dc
movies currently the ceo of warner brothers film
division has said that she wanted zack cider to
be able to finish his version of justice league
so that's why she green-lit the snyder cut and
gave him that 70 80 90 million dollars to finish
the movie but that they had no plans to do any
more justice league snyder cut sequels and zack
snyder himself sort of corroborated this said the
same thing he said he'd love to be able to do the
sequels but he'll believe they're going to happen
when he sees it he did say a long time ago that he
had developed a plan with jim lee to do the story
of the sequels as a comic book but that when a t
bought warner brothers it sort of got lost in the
shuffle but that he would do that again if there
was enough interest in it which i think there
is so there's actually pretty solid chance that
you could see that story play out in a comic book
series separately he also said that he had plans
to eventually do a batman prequel comic book for
ben affleck's batman just to tell his version of
a death in the family to explain the backstory on
how jared leto's joker killed robin that's part of
the reason why he added jared leto's joker to the
justice league snyder cut ending and all that new
footage he shot because he wanted to pay off some
of that storyline that he'd teased back in batman
v superman whereas normally you would just address
that and say like the ben affleck version of the
batman movie the other batman scenes at the end
of the film the epilogue scenes those tag scenes
of deathstroke and lex luthor were meant to set up
that ben affleck version of the batman movie that
would have come out between the justice league
sequels and while they've already moved on to the
matt reeves robert pattinson version of the batman
movie joe manginello was recently trying to build
hype for a deathstroke hbo max series and just
to explain what chris tario was saying about the
whole thing he did this huge therapy session style
interview with a magazine a little while ago where
he aired his grievances against the studio in
the making of batman v superman in justice league
and some of the biggest takeaways that were
when they brought him on to write batman v
superman nothing about the studio's plans at
the time for the dc movie slate made any sense
at least according to him like they didn't have
any solid plans they just knew that they wanted
some release dates they knew they wanted these
movies to come out but nothing about the way
they were bringing everything together with the
characters in the story made any sense and that
now they're mostly just letting each of the new
dc movie directors do whatever they want and that
when they want to do another justice league film
they'll just shoehorn all the characters that they
want into that and try to make it make sense so
hopefully that explains what's going on in the
studio right now but if we hear any news about
zack snyder doing more dc projects of course
i'll do a video about that what'll happen is
i'll try to do a fast nine trailer video and
my full falcon and winter soldier episode 5 video
will post this friday just like normal but leave
all your requests in the comments below there'll
be a lot more dc stuff happening really soon too
while you wait for everything everyone click
here for my justice league snyder cut ending
and in credit scene video and click here for that
brand new marvel falcon and winter soldier episode
5 trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!